self-belief comes from self-love right
the minute you fall in love with
yourself is the day the world will fall
in love with you almost 40 of the people
they are harmed by spinach almost have
one third of the people are harmed by
brock making money is a byproduct of
doing things that actually make people's
life better this is the way to live
healthy for long long time
evan how are you and here he is the one
and only naveen jane in the house as a
result of what i do
i've interviewed tons of people done
profiles and tons of people and my
community always tells me who they want
me to do next and when your name first
came up a couple years ago i didn't i
didn't know who you were and uh i looked
at some of your content and there's only
been three people that i've ever looked
at and then said oh my gosh i love this
person i need to dive deeper into their
into their content and you were one of
those three people and so it's like it's
amazing to have you here i love your
energy thank you for the content thank
you for sharing thank you for
encouraging people to to care more to
feel more to do more to be bigger and uh
it's not about have you here talking
with us honor to be with you and it's
really hard to get a brown guys to blush
but when you see all these kind things
about me it makes me blush
[Laughter]
i love it man so i mean there's so many
ways to go but i think one of the things
that i
love about you is the idea of the
moonshot
and that concept of just taking uh
taking your big shot most people settle
for a small life they settle for small
goals and they end up being unhappy and
you're the exact opposite you're full of
life full of happiness full of it every
time i've seen you full of energy and
going after big things so what is a
moonshot i know you've written the book
on it but for you how would you describe
the moonshot problem or a goal or a
mission that most people on the surface
believe is impossible if not very
difficult to get and these moon shots
are the problems when you actually solve
them it helps billions of people live a
better life so that means your moonshot
is something some people call that
you're not star someone that you know
you every day you
wake up in the morning you jump out of
the bed wanting to do that and you know
to me i find energy not in about the
work that i'm doing but the outcome of
that work that i'm doing i every day bar
none seven days a week i get up at four
am with the joy of i'm doing the work
that makes me happy
and you know we in this western society
we have this concept of something or
someone when i achieve that will make me
happy and an eastern philosophy is about
once you find the true happiness that's
inside you of doing the things it's a
karma it's the action you take that
gives you that happiness and it doesn't
matter how far you push that boundary
even if you never achieve that ultimate
goal but you push it farther enough that
someone else will come and stand on your
shoulder and take it across the finish
line guess what that is a success that
you can all be proud of i mean i love
how you bring it home the first time i i
heard of the concept was when i was
reading a book um by ted turner and his
father when he was uh when ted turner
was like in his early 20s his father was
in the advertising business and he had a
goal to be a millionaire have a million
dollars in my business and he did and he
hit his goal and then his father killed
himself the next day because he realized
that he's still the same guy and it
wasn't a big enough goal so then ted
turner decided i'm going to set a goal
so big that i never hit it in my life
because we want to play a big game that
we're chasing forever um and so i love
how you just kind of we label it
moonshot we're taking our big ideas and
big dreams and for my audience as
entrepreneurs they want to go and do big
things
so
let's workshop it maybe so i think about
what i'm trying to do
i think lack of belief is the world's
number one problem i think people don't
believe in themselves i think everybody
has i call it michael jordan level
genius at something
and whatever problem cancer whatever it
is you know the woman who solves cancer
should have already solved it but she's
an accountant at an accounting firm
hating her life instead of chasing down
her dream so yeah if that's my moonshot
or is that would you consider that
is something if successful so you ask
yourself god forbid i'm actually
successful in solving the problem that i
call my moonshot would it help a million
people 100 million people a billion
people live a better life and the reason
you ask for that is anytime you can
build a product or a service that helps
a billion people live a better life you
can create a hundred billion dollar
company 500 billion dollar company and
that is the goal making money is a
byproduct
of doing things that actually make
people's life better
making money should never be a goal in
itself it's always a byproduct right you
know i i may say so because
my wife hates my saying that you know
making money is like having an orgasm if
you focus on you're never going to get
it so you just have to enjoy the process
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i mean i love that uh so shout out
to your wife as well uh you know but so
so taking it taking that goal right so
if i want to sell the world's biggest
people don't believe themselves so the
problem is
not believing in themselves there are a
couple of things the people either have
a mindset of scarcity so they believe
that
or mindset of abundance the mindset of
scarcity says that everything is finite
if someone else has it i can't have it
or if i have it someone else is going to
be deprived of it right in a mindset of
abundance you see everything is so much
that we all can have enough of it and
people say how is that even possible but
look at air air is so abundant that we
never have to slap the person next to us
hey you took a deep breath that was my
ear why is that because we inherently
believe the air is in abundance that
means it's democratized and it's
demonetized now everything that we think
about that scares today is actually in
abundance it's in our mindset we believe
it's not energy
every 90 minutes more solar energy falls
on this planet than we use in the whole
year simply a matter of conversion of
the solar energy into useful form and
it's like same thing that happened to
the aluminium it was abundant on earth
but it was never available in a pure
form until the technology called
electrolysis came about that made it
abundant right now what is going to be
the electrolysis of solar energy that's
going to make it abundant and it's going
to be plentiful that means it's going to
be democratized and free and when you
have free energy you can have free fresh
water which is another big problem
facing the humanity right people have
dirty water and if you have free energy
you can distill the water you can
desalinize the water and suddenly when
you have free fresh water you can have
abundance of food abundance of crops
so point i'm trying to make is that
land people fight over land and you look
up we are just a tiny dot in our own
solar system our solar system is a tiny
dot in our galaxy our galaxy is
invisible in our universe right and our
universe may be invisible into the
multiverse the point is where is that
scarcity the other thing that stops aunt
from entrepreneur from succeeding is
they are afraid that they may their idea
may not work and what i
find amazing is
you as an entrepreneur you have to be
alive and the only way you know your
life is your heartbeat goes up and down
and up and down that means in life when
you don't have ups and downs and you're
looking for a smooth life what are you
looking for life of a dead person right
so people have to accept that there are
going to be downs people have to expect
them and accept them when they happen or
when something happens don't assign it a
label of good or bad simply say
it happened
universe is my friend
that means everything that happens
happens for a good reason that means it
is in my benefit that this happened
whatever that is and then when you have
that attitude you keep pushing forward
with every hurdle you get i love it i
love it well so let me let me pick your
brain further on that yeah if you were
to build a business around democratizing
self-belief
what would you what would you build what
would you create what would you sell by
definition self-belief comes from
self-love right that means the minute
you fall in love with yourself is the
day the world will fall in love with you
right it is the point is unless you can
love yourself how can someone else love
you when you can't believe in yourself
why would someone else believe in you so
to me the belief is an internal
mechanism when you are constantly
looking for someone else's approval you
have given them the remote control of
your happiness right so that you should
never ever look for other people's
approval you should share your genius
you should share your skills you should
share the you know what god-given gift
you have with everyone else but not look
to them to actually fulfill you i love
it people saying nuggets in the live
chat we've got naveen's nuggets here
this is great
uh so you talked about
democratization and demonetization
and
making money
not not you know the whole orgasm
analogy so how do we demonetize
something and make money build something
when you demonetize something it creates
opportunity as a catalyst to build solve
a problem that still remains unsolved
where there is still a monetization to
be had until you demonetize that and
that creates a foundation for the next
problem to be solved that you can
actually create a business around and
when you solve that you demonetize that
and you create a net platform so it's
really every single time you solve one
problem that helps you actually build
the next set of higher higher level
problems that you can solve
ultimately
until the world runs out of problems to
solve remember what happens is when you
are poor
all you want is a car when you have a
car all you want is a garden parking for
a car right
my point is it doesn't matter what you
have in life you always have the next
problem that you have to solve that
means every single solution ends up
simply creating yet another problem that
you can solve how do we get back to a
place of happiness just inside of that
because you've accomplished a ton and
so you know the problems multiply as you
get bigger and yet you're still happy
every day and bringing at least every
time i've seen you it's happy energy you
make me smile how do we maintain that
level of happiness as opposed to just
wanting more and finding new problems
things that inherently brings you joy
right and that joy comes from inside you
that you're doing the things that you
are set out to do
or if i may use the religious thing
you're doing god's work this is what
you're sent on earth to do and when you
find that purpose and there is no bigger
purpose in life to then make someone
else happy and when you do that in turn
it makes you happy because you're doing
things that you actually set out to do
we as humans doing things
for others or taking care of others is
actually built into our dna remember we
used we used to live in tribes in you
know savannahs of africa
and we knew if our tribe died we would
die and it was up to us to take care of
each other so our tribe would survive
and that's literally it's just a matter
of us finding that tribe that takes care
of each other not just ourselves but
each other
i love it
the other thing i love about your
message and your story is you always
seem to attack things as an outsider
where
you come in industries that you know
nothing about
take a beginner's mind and then just
revolutionize them where most people are
too afraid because oh i didn't go to
school for this or i don't i don't have
the background my family's not here talk
about the importance of your model i
guess of coming in as an outsider is
once you become expert at something
you become incrementalist or in my book
you become useless in a sense that you
can be 10 better than someone else in
the world but you will never be 10 times
better than someone else in the world to
be 10 times better you have to
fundamentally challenge the foundation
of what experts have taken it for
granted that means expert becomes expert
by actually accumulating the knowledge
that they believe is
you know that is what if they've taken
it for granted which is what makes them
an expert when you come from outside the
industry you're able to say what if that
is not true what if you can
fundamentally challenge that and then
suddenly you are able to rethink
reinvent and you can be 10 times better
than anyone else in the world and that
literally happens in every industry if
you look at today's disruptive
industries there is never a single
example where insiders actually
disrupted the industry right you look at
the taxi industry not by done by some
somebody in the taxi it was known by
uber hotel industry disrupted by airbnb
and you can now look at the automotive
industry done by tesla not by somebody
food or gm right it's similarly the you
know space exploration being done by
entrepreneurs from internet not somebody
from nasa or aerospace boeing or
mcdonald right and that literally
happens in everything in our healthcare
world it's not being done by hospitals
or doctors or someone is being done by
entrepreneurs like us who go out and say
what if we can prevent the illness from
happening in the first place rather than
actually take care of it when you get
sick that's amazing and and what a great
segue because you've got a great company
called vyom and i've got i just got this
sent to me so i have my it's still
unopened you know i'm waiting i was
waiting to talk to you before i went
through this uh so so tell us about vyam
your
big moonshot and then and then what am i
holding the fundamental belief of wyo
was what if we can understand
everything that's happening inside your
body tell you what is going on so we can
tell you hey
evan your biological age is this despite
your chronological age this is your
immune health this is your gut health
this is your cellular health this is
your mitochondrial health and it's not
like now enjoy then we tell you hey evan
you shouldn't be eating broccoli because
your sulfide production is too high
because sulfide production is
inflammatory and it requires a sulfate
which broccoli and cabbage and processed
fruit have don't eat a spinach because
your oxalate metabolism is not very good
and spinach contain lot of oxalate or
you need you don't need to be taking
vitamin b3 because your uric acid
production is high but don't take
curcumin even though everyone thinks
curcumin is healthy for you it's not
very good because your bile acid
production is too high but you do need
so you here are the foods you should be
eating and here is why here are the
foods you should be avoiding and here is
why here are the supplements you don't
need and here is what you do need every
day you need 22 milligram of elderberry
you need 27 milligrams of amylase you
know 29 milligram of barbarian and guess
what we make those capsules with only
those ingredients in that dosage for
each individual every month so as your
body changes we can't automatically
adjust your supplements that your body
need and amazing things happen evan we
now have over 325 000 people who have
analyzed their things
and we showed that within four to six
months when people do our follow or take
our supplement and follow our food
guidance suddenly
their diabetes comes down we showed that
hb a1c came down by 30
their depression comes down by 36
percent measured by phq-9 their anxiety
came down by 32
measured by a g87 or their ibs score
measured by ibs sss came down by 40
these are the things without drugs these
are the things using food as a medicine
this is what hypocrites wanted us to do
let food be thy medicine that die
madison with the food and that's
literally what we are doing is there is
no such thing as universal healthy food
and knowing what is good for you is
actually it's not about just because
green is good for you green actually may
be bad for you so it's literally knowing
what your body needs right now and as
your body changes we adjust your food
and that is the only way you can live
healthier so idea is not to live forever
ideas to live healthy as long as you
live
and i love the customized approach to it
because
if you went to your doctor and and said
hey broccoli or spinach is bad for me
nobody nobody would nobody would agree
but it might be you know it might be
good for 95 percent of people but for
that five percent but at least in our
data shows almost 40 of the people they
are harmed by spinach almost one third
of the people are harmed by broccoli
right so it is really entirely a lot of
people are harmed by taking a lot of the
things food that we take take it for
granted like curcumin right so if your
bile acid is high you shouldn't be
taking turmeric or curcumin
so it's really is individualized for
each person and what you have in your
whole hand is you're holding the key to
healthy life this is the way to live
healthy for long long time
and then you know obviously what we
learned from here we are able to build
the diagnostic test to be able to tell
you when you actually have early signs
of cancer when you have early signs of
ivd when you have early signs of natural
effort or any other disease and then our
goal is to be able to come up with the
drugs that we actually will cure the
disease not simply manage the disease
right today the chronic disease is
simply managed and you take a drug for
rest of your life and our goal is to
prevent the diseases from happening
diagnose them early and then have a cure
for the disease rather than simply
manage them i love it and for the
youtube audience check the link in
description below we're going to link
this up if you want to get your version
of this just like i'm about to go
through it so so what's in here i
haven't opened it
what's
once you open it up it looks just like
this
imagine living in a world where illness
is optional right inside that there is a
way to actually do a simple easy product
there are two tests you
a touch of your stool
and a few drops of your blood put in the
test tube and inside you put send it to
us and seven to ten days later in your
app it tells you exactly what's
happening in your body what foods are
good for you what foods are bad for you
and why
right and that's and by the way what
supplements probiotics prebiotics you
need vitamin mineral herbs digestive
enzymes amino acids probiotics
prebiotics everything you get right and
we make it so easy there is no grossness
in that it's literally so easy to use
and it is so simple and that's why it's
a more of a lifestyle product rather
than a medical father that you may have
yeah that's yeah that's literally
i i like it says okay two collect three
send pretty easy
how do i like getting the blood
said you touch it you lands and you
press the last few drops of blood and
there is a pipette to touch the drop of
blood it takes two drops out and you
squeeze it in the tube and you're done
yeah
wow that's awesome yeah okay so so i
mean i'm going to do this i'm going to
document my journey and see what comes
back and i'm
nervous and excited to see what the
results are hopefully your biological
ages are lower than your chronological
age uh a mile is 10 years lower so i'm
happy man
i love it and then okay so then what
happens so this gets sent to the lab
reports come back
uh supplements are recommended food you
know stop being in this et cetera
is this something that that you do every
four years once a month once a year you
do every four to six months so you can
see the changes for yourself right so
you can say hey this is my score now
look at this right so as you're not
following or following your
recommendation you can see it for
yourself so it's not based on faith i
think it works you can see the facts so
it's always is
you know follow the signs follow the
facts not the faith
i love it and then and then the results
go to my app and the supplements is
something that then you sell or i'm
finding somewhere else so what what am i
doing
that is very difficult but we make it
for you so we can you can buy it from us
or you can get it from someone else if
you want i love it well i'm gonna go do
this we'll see what happens here what
what was the
so what's the what's the
one day when we have no business to
diagnose any person or any any any
business to cure anything that means we
have succeeded in preventing all the
decisions from happening and that is the
ultimate goal is that no one ever gets
sick because they are actually are
eating right nutrients
lowering their stress sleeping well and
working and having enough movement in
their body so that they can actually
live healthier forever
i love it and what was the single
biggest
insight you got a couple of people
that i always thought were the healthy
things to eat because that's how i grew
up eating almonds and almonds were
turned out to be one of the worst things
that happened because it causes me so
much inflammation other thing was dairy
i mean daily was just an absolutely
deadly thing and when i stopped taking
dairy not only our last week i used to
have all kinds of digestive issues
they're all gone right for my wife they
were slight very different for her it
was things the biggest problem for her
was green leafy vegetables that broccoli
and cabbage and versus sprout and she
always just thought she was just lack of
energy and she thought that just normal
and it turned out just by changing the
diet now she said she doesn't even need
a nap because she's just full of energy
right so what people tell us is they
sleep better they have better mood
depression anxiety is gone they no
longer have acne or eczema or dry skin
people are telling us that you know all
the digestive bloating diet stomach ache
they're all gone so things that we used
to think are different diseases
different symptoms they're just simply
the
inflammation in their body that's
showing up as a different symptoms
it's funny how we take things like lack
of energy or lots of inflammation and
just feel like that's normal amazing
thing is unless you get better you don't
even know what better looks like you
just think it's normal like i'm 62. yeah
of course being tired at this time when
you're working 15-hour days is normal
god no i'm actually now i run up the
stairs two stairs at a time and i'm 62
imagine when i'm 70 and my biological
age is 40 i'll be running jumping after
climbing the mountains right and that's
really the idea is to be able to do
things you want to do not the things you
couldn't do
i love it well the man is davine jane
the company is biome here's the kit i'm
gonna go through the process myself
youtube there's a link in the
description below leaving any final
words to uh take us out on live your
dream dream to the fullest go out and do
things that people think are crazy and
they don't tell you that you're crazy
then you're not thinking big enough so
dream big and never be afraid to fail
because you only fail when you give up
so in the meantime keep pursuing your
moon shot and never let anyone tell you
that you can't do it thanks i love it
living chain everybody thank you man
appreciate you take care bye-bye if you
want to see the one-on-one i did with
deepak chopra check it out right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there every thought you have
is a magical lie
how do we live a life with zero physical
or mental weakness